we're celebrating the 50th anniversary
celebrating history commemorating that
landmark lineup from a half century ago
and the heinz history center
hosting a symposium tonight with all the
remaining members of that lineup al
oliver dave cash
gene klein's roberto clemente junior and
manny sankee and all there with rick
dayton
hilton's 21st start of the year is era
below two and a half a ton of strikeouts
163 of them at 114 and two-thirds
and he hits a line drive slicing toward
right center but it'll be run down by
luis robert who then throws it up into
the stands in right center
so one two three first for rodon
and also just called up today max
kranick his sixth appearance 18
punch-outs in 20 innings
on the ground
they get one
and they get mon kata the ground into a
double play and that is one of the
toughest guys in the history of baseball
to do that against
scoring
yes he did oh yeah
that'll do
third strikeout for rodol the double
doesn't hurt and it will bring up luis
robert
cannon shot down the left field line
inside the chalk for robert into the
corner it goes
let's see if they stop play sheets came
home the pirates put their hands up with
alfred in the corner
[Applause]
and let's see what the end result is
they will send sheets back to third
oh
crack the bat coming home
and called out at the plate sheets
is retired for the second out
not wasting any time thinking about that
out at first base coming right to it boy
yeah
stallings caught that ball and he there
was no plate to get to for sheetz is uh
yeah after the catch you're allowed to
block the plate he gets a shin guard
stacked up nice
[Music]
not the bat in the way
missed it
out to center
[Applause]
reynolds gets the out and the pirates
get out of it nice job by crannock and
the boys keep the white sox off the
board
for stallings now
on the ground garcia to second turn from
hernandez
whoa that was smooth
i thought layori might go to third
instead he's fun too
kevin went down to triple a and now back
up here on september 1st he had 11 home
runs
with charlotte
oh gavin gives it a run to right field
does it have enough the answer is yes
that major league uniform looks mighty
nice
on gavin sheets
this is thigh high it is middle in
that's the one if he were to order it it
would be there
and that
is a three run lead
defoe it's second one out
struck him out fastball up top
fifth strikeout for rodon
first and third two outs
and tucker is gonna drive in the run
smacking it the other way and three hits
for the pirates in the fifth and they're
on the board
it's usually a pretty good pitch to hit
and uh
you know maybe not even in the strike
zone borderline strike up there but
short little stroke there from cole
tucker longest hit streak in the majors
by far is joan right now at 15 games
monkatta
q shot shortstop can newman ace him
again the answer is no and that ball
nearly was gonna make its way
i don't know down 57 a while to bourbon
a or something yeah that's a base hit
for yuan so he extends his hitting
streak
three and two
on the ground to first moran to second
return pass to first is wide
and here comes abreu to score the sox
get a run out of that
and again second straight night a
pitcher covering on a possible double
play turn goes awry
this was not nearly as good of a throw
as last night anthony bondic comes on
for the 16th time his era a little over
five so he inherits base runners at
first and second
fair third base line and a long way to
go for alford into that corner
grondahl is home goodwin gets stopped
it's an rbi double and it's five to one
garcia continues to have a great couple
of days
[Applause]
comes into the ball game for the 14th
time
third base side moncada a breakneck pace
to get over there and he snaps it up for
out number two i mean he's just playing
a miraculous third base this is a
wonderful play
johan on a full out sprint with that
ball rotating back toward the field of
play i mean he's got a long way to go
boy the last couple of ball games you
can put a time capsule
on the defensive side for juwan montana
he's been brilliant
that is a tough out to make
bummers back out for a second night
here's anthony alford
does not look like fun
alford
wants to try to prove you wrong
he did
that is a long home run for anthony
alford
and he'll get one back for the box his
second home run of the year
430 rock 110 miles per hour
off the bat turning around 95 he's
getting it ready early gets the foot
down
throws that barrel out front
and that's the kind of power i mean
watch it looks so simple and easy and
effortless it just
jumps off the bat
liam and harris runs it first and second
he's facing the tying run
puts a charge into it and a base hit
tucker's going to come around and score
and stallings drives in the run here in
the eighth inning
popped him up
left side
garcia
makes the catch of the innings over
so here's gavin sheets the big blow
tonight was his three run homer in the
fourth
sheets center field reynolds back
kevin's done it twice
that is a sweet swing
first career multi-homer game he's
driven in four on the two home runs and
sox could have used that one
liam hendricks looking for a five-out
save it would be his 31st of the year
robert and setter as out number one
quickly for hendricks
[Applause]
[Music]
started as a starter now a reliever
couple organizations two down
[Applause]
and the sox win
hendricks
gets a five-out save and gavin sheets
supplies the thunder
you